so in the videos that i've been making
using these python examples i've been
using python 2. i've been using python 2
which is kind of the standard version of
python that most implementations are in
at the time of making this video but
there is also a python 3. there is also
a python 3 which is kind of the state of
the art version of python i guess you
could say it's the newest version of
python but it's not backwards compatible
when i say backwards compatible it means
that if you're running python 3 it will
not necessarily be able to interpret any
everything that is written in python 2.
so that's what we mean by backwards
compatibility you can't take a program
you can't take a program that was
written in python 2. so let's take a
program that's the program right there
and let's say it runs it runs fine in
python 2. if you take that same program
and try to run it in a python 3
interpreter it's not going to work so
this means so this is not
backwards compatible
backwards
compatible if this did work then python
3 would be backwards compatible and the
whole reason well you know this is
actually a nice understanding of what
even backwards compatibility means but
the whole point of making this video is
the the the program that i ran in the
last video will work in python 2. it
will work in python 2 but it will not
work in python 3. and it the reason why
it doesn't work in python 3 is that
python 3 has a different
version of this input function of this
input function over here
in python 2
if you if you if you use the input
function just like i used it and it you
know i put some i put some i put some i
put a a message here for the user of
what to input and when the user
inputs something it'll be returned to
the program it'll be returned to the
program fully evaluated so in this case
if the user enters a number i get the
number as a number so i literally get
the i get an evaluated i get the
evaluated expression
evaluated expression
so like we saw in the last few examples
if the user puts in a 4 then the number
4 will be put in the variable number if
the user inputs literally 3 plus 4 then
the number 7 will be put into the
variable into the variable number
in python 3 the input function does
something slightly different and it's
enough to break this program if you were
to try to run it in python 3. in python
in python 3 the input function the input
function doesn't return an evaluated
expression it returns a string and this
is a word you're going to hear a lot of
in computer science and i'll explain it
in multiple videos but it returns a
string
a string
of of what
the user input user
inputted
and you you're saying sal what is a
string and this is actually a good
introduction a string is a string of
characters so
to maybe make the difference if i if the
user inputs
if the user inputs right over here so
this is from coming from the user if the
user inputs
if the user inputs in the python 2
version 2 times 6 then what will be
stored in the variable number will be
the two times the six so it will be
twelve it'll actually be evaluated in
python three if the if we just did this
and the user inputted two times six so
once again the user inputs two times 6
then what's stored in the variable
number what's returned from this
function right over here is not going to
be 2 times 6 evaluated it is going to be
a string of characters that says 2
times 6. so this is this this string and
string is really you can just view it as
a string of characters it's a it's you
can kind of view it as some text of of
that's not actually interpreted in any
way so it'll actually return that string
of characters then you'd have that
string of characters put here in number
and then the function here range would
break down because it's like i'm trying
to take the range of like a word not
like a number here so that's why it
would break in python 3. so if you want
that original function to work in python
3
what you have to do
is put and so instead of just calling
input like this you have to and i'll
write it below this you would have to
write eval
eval and then write input
you and then you would write
input and then quotes all of the stuff
that i wrote up here
the colons close quote close parentheses
and then close and then close the eval
parentheses right over there and what
eval does is it can take a string of
characters it can take some text like
this and it'll evaluate it so what
happens is that in python 3 you'll get
this string and then when you eval it so
then you would do an eval on this
so you do an eval on this so you're
doing an eval on the input
the user puts some input so then you're
doing an eval with the user inputted and
then this will return
and then this will return
this will return 12. so in python 2 the
input function kind of does it all for
you python 3 it returns a string and
then you have to evaluate the string to
get 12. so if you try to do this on
python 3 and it broke
that is the reason why you got to put a
new vowel around it